[Music]
um so a question this is really just and
this is honestly it's an honest question
is this good dancing especially the one
dude who's the dude there in the in the
uh the white the white uh suit jacket
you know his solo dance he was just
standing there snapping his fingers
half-heartedly not impressed with that
that's my move if i'm in a wedding party
and you know if you're in a wedding
party and they do the thing like they do
at all weddings now we're at the
reception they make you walk in to music
with entrance music and you're supposed
to have this nice little cute little
dance with whatever bridesmaid they've
matched you up with and so for me it's
just that i'm just doing this as i walk
down or maybe i'll
you know i might shake the finger like
this this is my dance you know that's
all i'm doing so i can appreciate i can
relate to that guy in that way that he
can't dance i can't test but i expect a
little bit i expect a little bit better
dancing from a boy band